this video is sponsored by steel rising
which is now available on pc playstation
and xbox you can buy the game by
clicking on the link in the description
all righty
welcome everybody
i am playing steel rising available now
if you're watching on twitch
you can check the panel we'll put the
command in chat and you'll get a link to
play it otherwise i'll have a link in
the description on youtube
very excited about this game super super
interested in it um it previewed really
well uh and i'm loving the vibe of you
from the main menu
so we're gonna play first hour on
youtube or probably two hours on twitch
and basically jump in i'm expecting some
challenging combat a very cool setting
i know there are a lot of like different
abilities um
which give you different play style
options i don't know basically just the
game sounds awesome
so
let's
jump in shall we new game
enable assist mode
although still rising was designed to be
a demanding game in standard mode assist
mode allows players to experience the
game while tailoring the challenge to
suit their own preferences and abilities
please note however that by activating
this
mode some difficulty related
achievements will not be unlockable you
will have to start a new game in
standard mode if you wish to obtain them
we're just gonna stay on standard mode
for now
we can always check out assist mode
later if we need to i love the art too
i believe it's a pretty small team which
always makes me
you know more
interested so
just feel like they can get really
creative
assist mode would definitely be good for
um
accessibility for sure
i wonder if i can check the settings
when you see some of the
some more accessibility options
and i will say i did notice a very long
loading screen when i started the game
up so
i'm expecting um
lengthier loading screens i don't
believe the game is broken
that said
again very pretty odd
it's not so bad
okay
it's a very interesting era to set a
video game in not special
oh powder
you know actually i think i'm in no mood
for games right now
hmm
how much longer will it be kept here
it's literally starting with marie
antoinette cause
this is the price to be paid for
spoiling the masses you don't understand
gabrielle
the king sent us here long before the
city went up in flames
he knew what was about to transpire
i think he is somehow involved in these
events oh come now marie
he can be misguided
tempered at times but he's no nero
then why have we been wouldn't it be a
huge
crazy plot twist if you play as marie
antoinette play some [ __ ] up you do not
the children
they'll soon be out of harm's way i am
most certain of it this clary will take
good care of them
for now at least we are safe
good uh cake references in the twitch
chat they're the shadow guards
we are still protected
the king just preferred to use
a different sort of guard
yeah so i think that these automatons
play a pretty big part or jailers
they won't even let us leave this room
gabrielle well it's a pretty sick room
you should have seen my studio apartment
the king
that room is bigger than my current
apartment i think first our darling
sophie
then our beloved son
my poor sweet angel
they didn't let me say goodbye
i wasn't even allowed to see him
that's pretty simple
something inside me is crying out
telling me he's still of this world at
times
i wonder if it's authentic art i'm so
afraid what do you fear my queen
everything everything horrifies me
the king's roth
his army and indefatigable automats that
mr the vocal saw has built for him
the charlatans who advise him who are
now more powerful than ministers
what happened to my son
what will happen to the children that
god has deigned to leave in my care i
won't let any harm come to them
this i promise you
but how it was a very interesting way to
start again
all is not lost because i don't think
you play as either of them
this new bodyguard of yours
ah
all right
that's cool that's a cool intro we like
that
okay ooh that could be gold
well i like that one that's that's
actually sick
wig
i should choose the face first
i'm also like i'm not sure if i can go
masculine or feminine damn she cute
she's super cute
i like that one
that one's cool nah that's that's
definitely the coolest
the hot one
oh one
okay you can be bodyguard soldier oh
sorry i need to update my
my twitch
to say what i'm playing let's do horizon
there we go
okay it's robocop in the 1700s it
totally is
so bodyguard body of work heavy weapon
special move block i don't tend to like
a heavy weapon
or a grenade really
heavy weapon light weapon i'm gonna go
with one of the light weapons dance up
almond fans
that's cool glass corbattens okay it's
between these two
flame grenade explosive projectile that
can ignite an enemy it's pretty standard
dances are highly resilient and can
chain attacks together in quick
succession to immobilize enemies and
inflict critical hits
agility and figa
alchemists favor alchemical weapons that
can ignite freeze or electrocute their
enemies and cause persistent elemental
afflictions
that sounds the most magical so we're
gonna go
this is tough
special move is block oh i it just seems
the most wizardy which is what i always
choose but that
look i'm gonna do the dancer
just because it's really unique
doing it
did i have a face covered that whole
time by the way my bad sorry i might
have
you'll see she's cute
that is now somehow able to speak
yes but it is loyal to you
that's all that matters
is such an interesting thing managed to
escape the chateau
it could be your eyes and ears in paris
and if perchance the other automats were
to go after it
you won't attempt anything foolish
i cannot see you sometimes you just have
to slap your friend and say they
shouldn't do anything foolish you know
what i'm saying
the king must be stopped the very
kingdom is at stake
go and find vocal soul at his workshop
niles
he surely holds the secret to these
tireless automats okay so we're trying
to help these two ladies out of this
room perhaps he will know something
about the death of my son
how am i to leave the chateau grounds
madame
go to the riverbank
at the far side of the grounds
from there you can take a boat
you know it's a good start to an rpg
when you're excited
like it's just it's just cutscenes so
far
what if he is the one who is responsible
for this unrest
what focal song has done
only song can undo
that's entirely too much hair that's all
i need to say
okay
feels pretty good feels like a little
bit like nia okay so lock on
dodge
cool fans
oh that's
sick i don't have a block do i no
do i pick something up quick access belt
you can assign consumables to the quick
access belt so that you can use them
anytime
go to the inventory to assign oil
how do i go to the inventory down okay
okay
okay
and then it'll be uh-huh
whoa
you what
yes dude
[Laughter]
ah unbelievably hyped about that can i
injure myself again so we can see that
again
that was sick
okay each weapon has an attacking or
defensive special move
nice
oops i just accidentally did it for some
reason i want to press x to hit
i have a lock on
overheating and rapid cooling of course
because i am automaton-esque
actions consume endurance when aegis
runs out of endurance her gear is
overheating she can no longer perform
the following actions attack jump dodge
when overheated you can trigger rapid
cooling which can instantly restore an
amount of endurance depending on your
timing however this inflates a certain
amount of frost damage as shown in the
following gauge
note using it too soon after overheating
will prolong the overheating
okay
actually i did not i just didn't
register any of what that just said it's
like i read every single part of it but
i didn't register what i needed to do
i completely just like didn't
pay any attention to what that just said
to me
that's my bad i'm sure i'll figure it
out like i know that i read every word
that was on the screen just then
okay my bad
i mean it's a familiar endurance system
i feel do i automatically get it back
yeah i do okay
it's it's
it's a soulsy
which i like
look at the way she jumps to with the
heel what a cool animation okay very
stylish
nice nice nice nice nice
give me things rusty key that's probably
gonna be my way out but i want to kill
the others
let's do it
hello
oh i overheated
it's not so bad
two at once is kind of tough
yeah okay so i wanted to check there if
if there's uh any um break
um to see if like if i hit them right
before they hit me if it stops them and
the news is that it does not which i
think i generally kind of prefer it's
more patentless
so there's no interrupt is what i'm
trying to say
nope
so i think you're gonna have to be a bit
meticulous too which is also cool
we're into it we're under it no stagger
yes
it's always worth uh testing out with a
game like this
when you jump into it you know what i'm
saying
oh yes for those asking
what platform i'm on i am on uh pc my
friends
and yeah the specs i don't know off by
hand i apologize
um i can no i can block scott
i can block
and it looks cool as hell
you know i didn't check that
oh there is that looks like a parry
right mobilization aegis's light weapons
are able to inflict immobilization
damage as shown in the immobilization
gauge that's what that is
when the gauge is filled the enemy's
enemy is temporarily immobilized leaving
them open to a critical hit okay
cool
there are there totally is a power
so cool
at least like that seems to be a little
parry right
i think so
little baby perry
okay
assume i'm supposed to just go straight
out here i really want to loot but
doesn't do that kind of game
thank you thank you thank you thank you
is there anything over here or is this
just a loop just a loop okay
rusty key new area the gardens
but which path to follow saw so many
which which way to go oh hey
nice
what's the little freeze that i have on
there
i'm sure
so it doesn't seem like there is
anything to loot outside of what's on
the corpses which is like extremely
comforting to me because otherwise i
have to compulsively explore
absolutely every
nook and cranny of every video game
that's all i'm saying okay i'm gonna
read this one
activating vestals activating a vessel
creates a checkpoint where aegis kit
will be repaired if she breaks okay this
is like a bonfire
upgrade attributes by spending anima
essence upgrade equipment weapons
barrette and modules by spending
materials obtain equipment okay
cool let's check it out
hey you cute
dude this design is rad i didn't expect
any of this
[Music]
kind of bioshocky
the freeze was the part that i read but
didn't register when you run out of
stamina you can hit triangle rapidly to
regain stamina if it applies some freeze
to you cool thank you i appreciate that
i can't believe i said every single word
but didn't hear any wild
um
okay
power would give me oh wow okay we got a
lot of options down here
anima essence
i have 771 level up is need a thousand
health is 250
durability
okay i see
i see i see i see we can't afford
anything yet but good to look at module
slots
cool
very cool weapons armored fans level one
characteristics physical power affinity
agility affinity alchemy affinity this
can get pretty deep i think folks
and buret
number of doses two to three
all right
but i can't do anything just yet right
it's just telling me to check it out
boutique
hmm
okay there's a fair amount of stuff
going on here let me go our chemical
capsule the most revolutionary weapons
used by the royal mechanical army employ
this are chemical ammunition
well their mechanics composition and
manufacturing classified they break with
the science of enlightenment drawing
instead on alchemical principles
that have slowly fallen into disuse
i don't know what this does for me
essence of a lesser spirit harsh but
fair
[Laughter]
the artificial alchemical essence in the
form of
tiny amount of anima essence
wait so that will give me anima
out of my essence explosive grenade
ordinary oil vial
i feel like maybe i'll just do that
granite cobblestone loose cobblestones
can uh
can be thrown at enemies to draw their
attention in the days leading up to the
attack by the mechanical army parisians
who refuse to accept the clockworks
clockwork tyrant's threats i'm very
excited about this game
okay
in simulation elixir elixir when
designing the royal army's alchemical
arsenal lightning-based weapons were the
most challenging to develop there had
been several cases of automats
destroying themselves in their own
formation attacks
so the development of this in in
simulating ins insulating
its insulation elixir inch
why does that sound so weird insulation
that's how you say the word
why does it sound wrong
uh the development of this insulating
elixir which acts as an antidote okay
that seems like a handy thing to have
too
i don't know yet i'm not gonna do it yet
i'm not gonna do it yet body of work
whoa
dude that's cool
i'm in fans we kind of already have
okay so we can oh that those looked up
too damn okay
okay okay okay
grade one will to live module this
module slightly increases ages armor and
balance
i think i might buy that
done
and then
we can go back to upgrades and no it's
probably equipped with somewhere else
equipment
hat
bye bye bye
thank you oh no autonomous anatomy and
the nibblonians thank you thank you
okay um modules is what i just bought it
auto slotted oh no it didn't okay let's
go sloppy's locked
reduces internal frost damage caused by
rapid cooling ah that seems handy let's
just wait till we unblock slot b then
shall we
i already have a side quest
in the memory of the dolphin the queen
sub still echoed in aegis's mind the
king his loss just mind to grief
etc
codex
love the codex also very good for
accessibility always very good for
accessibility means that uh
players with cognitive issues especially
can have something to consult if they
get lost but it happens to all of us if
you take time of playing a game or
whatever
codex is a really good thing to have
all right
we need
still a bunch more essence let's keep
rolling
you have just obtained a new module oh
open the module menu yeah i can't do it
yet
nice to know though um
oh that was an accident
not locked on
i think i healed by accident
ah it's very hard switching between
games where attack is x or all square on
one thing and not on the other
that is not the game's fault
i'm gonna check this way first my friend
are you chasing me
i don't know you could do that
lots of them
[Music]
missed that's a shame
oh gosh oh things aren't looking good
for me
i should have gone that way
mistakes were made
wait does blocking not actually block
all of it
ah blocked a second too late
that was my bad it was my bad
it just is broken and it's my fault
okay
oh it does remain in the place where
i just need to play a little bit slower
by now at least until we
get a weapon that does a bit more damage
i think
all right let's go for
you first
oh you did too
who was that for
or me
you could break my block
i didn't know that either
well now we know
okay take that
okay
i was just out of stamina they well
maybe i was just out of step but i felt
like maybe because i got hit while i was
out of stamina is what broke the block
right
i don't think using the block
is what did it where are you coming from
the absolute punk
a lot of games can't do staircase combat
it can be really hard
nice work all right look at us go
hitting people on staircases the future
is now baby okay do i have a map i don't
think i do i just don't want to miss
anything
i want to go everywhere which way
oh no
oh no
how am i finding the combat so far
i think i've pretty much figured it out
for this enemy type and this weapon
right and
it's pretty simple i think i like it it
it i feel like it's definitely gonna get
challenging ah okay i didn't realize it
holding it wouldn't apparently not
i expected to after i got hit because i
was still holding the block button for
me to block but no you have to re-engage
um yeah it feels good
but i also like look forward to it
expanding
i want to see more
that's what i'm saying
is i just want to see
more back up back up back up felicia
don't run as fast as me i probably
should have got a ranged weapon that
sounds fun
damn it
yeah it's gonna be a fun challenge for
sure
once you get the hang of it i think
a chest
what is it
this one
equipment hat
let's go baby
my lady milady milady melanie milady
all right
the jumping is very cool
um so there's a dodge it's just not a
dodge roll that's my dodge
it's just not a dodge roll
thinking we go this way
this is just so romantic down here
okay
just it sort of feels like we're on a
date
oh stealth oh wow i [ __ ] that up
didn't it
bad news everybody i pressed the wrong
button
i pressed the wrong button i pressed
l1 when i was first to press l2 oh so
far back
this time i am not going to press square
not gonna do it
didn't do it
work look at us not present square
you love to see it
oh i should have done that there but
still
that seemed like a
interrupt there maybe i just have to
time it really specifically
hello look at you jolly running over
that's like when my dog sees me when i
get home
looks just like that
she's so jolly
okay where's the other one
beautiful
okay
is there something like very big in that
direction
you can hear something large to the left
oh hello big boy
hello there
it looks like grievous
okay
i needed all the breakfast
i mean
get dunked on
it's so peaceful
another chest i would like to see what
is up with it
like this
let's go
that's gonna be a health module
i'm interested in that oh i didn't
expect you to do that so fast
who was that for you just like trimming
some grass out here or what
good day um somebody killed a man
should i report that
a man or woman is dead
anybody
well not my problem i guess
maybe he's just sleeping
it hap it will no that
just uh
makes it less compelling are these
automats or are they humans i think
they're humans that looks like a whole
ass man
you hate to see it you hate to see it
what's this
spooky gas
what's going on out here
the swiss guard killed by the automats
that replaced them
yikes
so it's got like an alternate history
which is always fun
defeat the unstable automata to activate
the vessel oh that's interesting okay
governor da after confirms that no
command was given to replace your
company with the detachment of automats
i therefore urge you until further
notice to keep your distance from these
machines and to inform me of any signs
of hostility do not engage unless her
majesty the queen is in danger
reinforcements are on route
so they weren't
actually like hired to replace
the gods somebody else sent them in
by the looks of things
hello big boy
[Music]
bad time to heal bad time to heal it
works out in my favor
okay
another one i do not need two of you at
once right now
oh gosh okay
this isn't gonna go well this is not
gonna go well i'm going to go the whole
way back
can you just go away
oh god i'm just trying to scope it out
ah oh no
well i do the blocking is very good
here's the good news
the timing the timing is not
the timing
not so good all right
give me
a thousand of these i can only afford
one
all right
couple more of that we'll do it
i think
nice
i'm glad there's no loading screens when
you um
visit that thing
beautiful
you keep facing that way
these two it's a bit harder to stealth
because there's two of them
okay there we go
as i was saying ah
no look on him thank you
so cool
beautiful
they gave me an oil vial too that's nice
it's an accident didn't mean to do that
okay oops
and another one
get one more
i don't care if you hit me you're just
here for me to grind anyway
i don't care
where you at there you go
cool that animation works up the
staircase that's neat
um this one you can also get these
oh
beautiful
this one
we can't really do this way to be honest
all right
another one
three seems good
i'm just gonna get another oil while go
back to that seven
okay
good day sir i said good day
yeah
just in time
ah
oh i got stuck i got stuck i got stuck i
got stuck
that was pretty
all right
we are going to buy
an ordinary vial
and an explosive grenade
and then we are going to go back
to the boss
and see how we fail
sounds good
to me
i'm not going to see here nothing to see
here nothing to see here nothing to see
here not going to see here
i got an achievement
okay gotta take out this guy
just in case
beautiful
all right
and then
you can come up first if you want that's
fine
okay two hits that's not my favorite
don't love that
my bad
should i just go back
i probably should
that's so cool
let's roll
thank you for the red jacob with a party
of 37 welcome everybody playing a game
just came out today i believe called
steal rising check it out
if you put the command
in the chat
you can buy it it's very fun definitely
a challenge but i'm enjoying it
or you can click the panel on the side
too
on twitch
boom
let's go baby
i have a large robot to kill i'm gonna
be honest i also don't think this is the
one
which maybe makes the grinding pointless
but here we
are i just don't feel like i'm ready yet
you know
you've never come this way before what
are you doing
you don't go this way
no
has he seen me
is that what it is he's still moving
slowly maybe he has seen me
i don't know if he did i think he just
maybe was trying to investigate the
noise or something
thank you cs king mobile for gifting us
up the jacob pool
all right
jump right over here
get started
boom
one
two
three
[Music]
he missed
ah the sweep
it looks like a stab but it's a sweep
[ __ ] endurance already i can see that
happen oh god oh god oh god oh god
panicked
just do something do something do
something
don't play with your food damn it i
thought i dodged that
you suck i hate you and you suck
i just thought you should know how i
feel
oh you too far away nope
oh god
[Music]
oh
so sweet
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i'm out of stamina
ah
oh i changed my lock on
damn i've got to stop missing that that
one like moment where he slows down and
i keep missing it well come on now
oh gosh oh gosh where's the other guy
he's over there i know he is
is that the slowdown
we did it
get out of my face son
you're dead you're so you're the most
dead anyone's ever been
get out get out of here
it's a fun fight i enjoyed it i had a
good time and now i have unlocked module
keys you've just obtained a module key
aegis has several slots for modules that
augment her stats and alter the
behavioral certain mechanics the slots
have levels that allow ages to fit
increasingly powerful modules to unlock
a slot with the module key you just
obtained go to the upgrade menu at a
vest all note you can equip modules at
any time from ages module menu
um what happened to the other guy
are you still over here bud
you know it would be really silly
if right now i
got into combat when i should be going
to the module to save surely the bosses
stay dead though right the boss is
surely stated surely surely the bosses
state it
surely he's not coming back
thank you for the raid so long
appreciate it hi everybody we are
playing steel rising
games just come out i'm enjoying it a
lot so far this is a good time
uh put the command still rising in the
chat if you want to check it out
upgrades baby let's go
what do we want to upgrade
power
physical damage and impact
health
engineering
vigor
i kind of do think i want to do vega
agility physical damage and mobilization
i'm thinking i'm going to go bigger
let's do it
and then
let's buy some tanks
am i where did they go
oh
did i buy out all of the
help
that's not good
trust the explosive grenades we'll do it
for now at least
i can get more upgrades oh yeah i have a
module slot don't i
confirm and then we can equip
i only got one uh we can equip the
module that i got
in here
okay we've got two
this module slightly increases health
the complex union of elemental alchemy
and precision mechanics
armor balance when our health is at our
lowest i'm going to go with
that one's already equipped right yeah
i'm going to go with that's that's
interesting oh omar spelled the the
british english way
that let's go
uh yes perfectly they definitely do heal
you over time i was aware of that yes i
was just trying to get them to heal over
time quickly
uh but i did see that
uh okay anything to loot
just keep moving let's keep keep on
swimming
hello mate
so i guess you can stagger if you used a
heavy attack and i just keep mostly
using a light attack
can i go through these
oh that's neat
didn't expect that that's cool
very cool
yes please
i can't go back that way damn it it's
another way to search oops oops
new weapon
don't mind if i do
what is it
a musket
okay
how do i swap weapons uh-huh
alright
alchemical hand cannon and alchemical
afflictions you acquired a hand cannon
just like her enemies weapons aegis's
own weapons can cause alchemical damage
flame frost and formination when she
uses alchemical capsules for each such
attack
alchemical damage fills a gauge which
when full triggers an affliction which
lasts until the gauge is depleted flame
affliction ignites its target of course
frost affliction freezes
oh i can thaw faster by attacking
interesting uh fulmination affliction
electrocutes its target
all right
off that win let's keep going
hello sir
that's oh i forgot that i had changed
weapons
wait it doesn't use any
it doesn't use stamina but it requires
capsules
that's cool
interesting wow okay so as i pick up
those those alchemical capsules
i'm gonna start like i guess swapping
between them as like ammo types
i did already know that but thank you um
and then i guess like maybe it'll be
like depending on what enemy but the
interesting thing is i can damage myself
that's cool
i'm into it
hello sir
how do you do
thank you for that good day
and i'm assuming i can't go through here
i can't oh you look scary
is that a hop
oh look at him
oh boy
okay all right i'll see you soon i'm
sure my friend
any minute now
oh my god it's like uh into the tunnel
damn okay i didn't expect this
back up back up back oh i froze it did i
oh did i freeze myself
you are very passive
which is kind of nice to see that like
enemies don't behave the same way
you shouldn't
where did you come from just up there
jeez
okay
thank you brick boy
uh yeah the webcam lags i'm not gonna
fix it again
it is what it is it happens every time
hello
it's nice to see you
it's right there
the lock-on is super important in this
game
ah i didn't realize that
i keep missing it
i don't think so
hello hello
and good day oh again alana you really
better stop paying up just a smidge and
more attention to that just a tiny
smidge
nice work lads
i said good day
another one of these
oh okay
we're going to get some traversal here i
suspect
that's cool
not on my watch
oh you can block
oh that's interesting
they're very cool
nemesis claws
quiet a compass you can assign compass
to the quick access belt so that you can
use it at any time to see the desk the
way to your destination
that's cool
where is it
inventory
compass
do that for now
the riverbank is just beyond this wood
very cool
i love that so much
yeah just a lot of creativity in the
animation whoever animated this know
that i am very impressed with you person
who doesn't know me or or care about my
opinion
just know that i am impressed you
animated your little heart out and it's
awesome
i wonder what the purpose of coming up
here is
if not to collect things you have things
for me
maybe this is a thing where later i can
i can climb it but not now
it doesn't seem like i can why
why would you let me out
i mean
do you know what i mean
i don't seem to be able to
i mean obviously we're gonna come back
here at some point because
um
there was that that gate that i passed
that it said i didn't have the tools to
open
yes hello
don't mind if i do
use vessel
upgrades
i can afford another upgrade
i can
i mean i could use some more attack
i don't feel like i need more health
just yet that badly the endurance is
what's getting me
but if i just increase my
let's just do that
let's do both do you know what i mean
boutique
we haven't really got nothing oh i
should have been using those too
because that's how you
distract the enemies so you can get
either the easiest stealth kills
this game has more to offer than i am
taking from it
actually let's equip those
granite cobblestone equip
i wonder how often you'll need the
compass
um occasionally try
didn't wipe on this guy
which way are you facing
i don't know what that which part is the
back
is which part is this the back
yeah okay
okay
uh
i'm gonna get burned
just like her enemies weapons aegis's
own weapons can cause alchemical damage
when she uses our chemical capsules for
each such attack alchemical damage fills
a gauge which when full triggers an
affliction which lasts until the gauge
is depleted flame affliction ignites its
target
causing continuous damage it just can
extinguish the fire faster by torching
noted
frost affliction freezes to target yeah
okay
here we go gone
oh this one is
i didn't okay i didn't expect you to
have all that in you
because usually you don't
you're a little spicier
my friends my fine friends
you're a little spicier than your
friends atop the hill
you got some spice in your
see life oh tight i wonder if
uh
it gave me the compass here because
we're getting like more pathways here
no i don't think so
get out of my face it does look like a
much bigger area
[Music]
really wow okay
and another one oh this is hot boy
big halfway
and his big hop adventures
oh
did you just immediately deplete
my stamina with one kick
you're just like the boss i fought i
don't want anything to do with you
no no
he was already a big enough joke i don't
need another one of you
you think just because you're little
i'll want anything to do with you you're
wrong ah
he's actually not that bad
we're all right with it get out of here
can i do anything with the well
why is there a seat on it
also it doesn't go anywhere
it's just
for what for what purpose does this well
exist
i would like to know
okay
thank you improving the oil buret ooh i
would love to
open upgrades menu in a vessel and use
la voicer catalyst to increase the
number of doses to improve the amount of
health
yeah doses where is it it's here
i don't remember where i came in
maybe i shouldn't have made fun of that
uh
compass so hard
what's that
some sort of
trumpet
they play music
what
okay
everybody's cool liking the designs a
lot
shouldn't make that much noise
definitely my back
hello
oh thanks for waiting i really
appreciate it
really means a lot
oh i did not time that the way i thought
i did i was like nice a lot of finesse
a lot it was wrong
it's probably a waste but
why not oh thank you arizos thank you so
much
don't go in there
no sir all right
and solution alexa
that's okay that's the way out but i
don't want to do it yet
oh hello
hey
oops i
wanted to heal actually though
i feel good about how many of those that
i've wasted but that's okay
life comes at you fast
let's stop oh
it's not this way
is it out this way
[Music]
maybe
it might be yeah you are
hello my friends
upgrades
hmm
i should really be just like saving more
okay so this is what i wanted to do was
upgrade that number of doses for sure
excuse me
i never sneezed once always twice
um okay
wait was there something else that i
missed
no
i can't afford any of that no
why are you still blue
should replace the ones of those that i
burned to the ground and
we could buy more capsules now i suppose
they're pretty cheap
yeah there is limited inventory huh
that is
very much my bad all right
gotta fight some homies again i think
still don't know which way you're
actually facing
because you
front your back look the same but i'm
sorry
it's probably harsh but
two cards
aerial combat
i didn't know i could do that
i really want to fight that big boy
again can i avoid him
i reckon i can
some of these areas do seem really good
for grinding but i'm like
brian if it turns out
fans
eat fan
okay
let's roll baby
let's see what is up we have reached the
banks
take a boat did you paulie
there's so many areas back there that i
didn't go to though
this boat will take me to paris
i hope it's not far love because
you are a robot
and this does not look uh super well put
together
oh there's that boy as that boy i saw
[Music]
i don't feel good about it i don't feel
good about it
oh my god
he does just he just does too much
damage
i read out already
oh no
wasted that okay
that's pretty cool
ah
okay i don't remember how to get rid of
uh i think i need uh hang on
game doesn't pause for that does it i
don't think it pulls this because i
think i do have one
i just don't have it equipped
[Applause]
[Music]
you hate to see it
all right at least i'm not electrocuted
anymore
oh
i'm out i don't know what you want me to
do
[Music]
okay there's about a range of that one
take that
hang on
i didn't think it would work to be fair
[ __ ] running out of goddamn stamina
eat gravel
oh it did do minus one
we aren't going to make it through this
fight okay
that's just the reality of the situation
it is what it is
it's a nice big area
so that's good
[Music]
i missed a [ __ ]
that was like such good aim
i'm shook
i didn't think it was gonna hit me i
really thought i was gonna be okay
it's not like i thought i was gonna get
through that on the on the on the first
try anyway right again very big thank
you to steel rising for sponsoring the
video make sure you check out the link
in the description to buy the game it is
available on pc playstation and xbox